foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
oh the walls are closing in and there's
another investigation
crimes of Grandpa poopy pants the Cheeto
Ducks q and honor Southern districts of
New York it seems it seems that truth
social is a fraud
ah good against it who called it I don't
know maybe I've been calling it fraud
social the entire time welcome it's
Wednesday March 15th you are here at the
Tony Michaels podcast I am the Tony
Michaels as I am everyone Wednesday and
every weekday Newton Eastern 11 Central
nine Pacific
on YouTube and Twitter and twitch and
simulcasting from the Midas touch
Facebook page and our Facebook page
we're off our band yesterday was the uh
the celebration of being off our seven
day suspension on YouTube A lot of
people are wondering where the show was
at we're all over the Internet folks
we're playing hide and seek because they
don't like how I speak
[__] them oh [__] I'm speaking of [__]
them I want to thank everyone who bought
uh [__] em hats yesterday you guys
really like the Vodka mats
I guess I really had no idea so I'm
extending the promo code for 10 off the
[__] em hats until the weekend oh you
know what I'll do it through the weekend
so Sunday night at midnight be your last
chance to use the promo code hats10
that's hats10 at
hats.dtonymichaels.com or you can just
go to the Tony michaels.com go down and
select the hat store link
it'll take you to the hat store you can
use the promo code hats10 or podcast and
get 10 off your order of [__] em hats
there was people that were ordering in
three or four at a time so thank you
very much for your support I'm glad that
you guys are going to be out there
wearing [__] hats just do me a favor
when you get them uh send some pictures
to me on social media let's see those
[__] em hats when you get them because
there's going to be a lot of them out
there so send it to me on Twitter or
Facebook and I'll try to I'll try to
share those photos as well if you want
me to you know what I mean if you want
to just show me and you don't want me to
share it to send it in a DM and tell me
that I still like to see your the
[__] hat
so thank you very much for um for all
your support there and go to the
tonymichaels.com for all the support
here at the the Tony Michaels podcast
you can follow us on social media you
can follow us on Facebook at the Tony
Michaels of course if you still have a
Facebook account you can follow us on
Twitch you can actually link your Amazon
Prime account to Twitch and give us your
one free subscription you can download
every single episode on Apple Spotify
and Google and follow us on Twitter at
Tony Michaels pod and of course you want
to sub here at the Tony Michaels podcast
YouTube channel and also over on the up
wire where we were hiding uh for a week
so go to up wire the upwire.com that's
the upward.com and follow their social
media accounts as well welcome
[__] big news big news
is it really news is it really news that
the spec is being used still under eight
million dollars of Russians money is
this supposed to be something new that
Donald Trump is doing now is laundering
Russians money into the [__] out of here
with that [__] of course it's not new
and of course of course
he Trump the Trump organization his
supposed real estate company is going to
be smashed up with a hammer by the
Attorney General of New York uh tis
James she's going to cut that [__] down
like a fresh cut tree
it's all all but in receivership at this
point anyways so he opens up Trump media
he tries to do a spack with some other
company to fundraise about a billion
dollars and we find out oh wait oh there
was eight million dollars being wandered
of Russians money from the Caribbean huh
isn't that funny you know the other
funny part
about the Trump story
and and and money and fraud
get this
you know you know Steve Bannon is that
piece of [__] you know who that traitor
is Steve Bannon you know he's he's he's
he's been convicted of of uh uh skating
a subpoena of Congress and he held in
contempt criminal contempt he's waiting
on his appeal
to go to prison
the Chinese National
the boat the yacht the yacht the big ass
boat
the elitist boat that Steve Bannon was
on when he was arrested that guy who
owns that boat
he's been indicted on fraud charges in
the sdny
so the legal woes closing in on Trump
those walls are getting closer and
closer and closer which brings me to a
Great Clip and some great clips that
we're going to show the Ari milber show
yesterday oh my God the beat on MSNBC
Trump's lawyer I don't even know what
this [__] chucklehead's name is this
is supposed to be his good lawyer too
oh
my God this is supposed to be the one
that knows what he's doing unlike Alina
hamba or Christina Bob
this one in particular
that is defending him
in the Stormy Daniels case where it
looks like the uh Michael Cohen is
testifying again today
on felony charges it looks like what the
grand jury's gonna bring his felony
charges
wish the interview with the lawyer
that's going to defend him and I hope
that's the lawyer that does defend him
oh my god oh sweet Jesus
please please let that [__] and
defend Donald Trump in court where in
the [__] does he find these people
I mean I know I know he's running out of
options because every single person that
[__] defends Donald Trump and defends
his lies ends up losing their [__]
law license Rudy Giuliani Sydney Powell
crazy Lynn wood Jenna Ellis damn near
lost their long license
she was just censored because she was
willing to admit
in an open statement an open court that
she lied ten [__] times
she should lose her law license
the attorneys that are trying to defend
Carey Lake in Arizona they're going to
lose their law it goes on and on and on
so no wonder they're scraping at the
bottom of the barrel
to find attorneys that will even
represent these fools and risk their
risk not getting paid and losing their
law license
it really is something else speaking of
Trump's attorneys and this this Chinese
National I guess his name is Miles
something I don't know miles go you or
do you or I don't know I don't know you
know Steve bannon's buddy the yacht guy
that that defrauded uh his supporters
online for like a billion dollars or
some [__]
that guy is apparently really
good friends with Rudy Giuliani
and he shows up at Mar-A-Lago I don't
know I'm just you know
it seems it seems like a connects to B
and B connects to all Trump allies
everywhere it's almost like all of it's
a grift all of its fraud
and all of it is designed to just fill
their pockets hmm
I wonder why that is I wonder why that
is in other news in other investigations
apparently svb the management of svb and
the investors of svb are under
investigation
by the FBI they're making sure there was
no
um um
in discrepancies at foot they don't they
want to make sure there was no Insider
training because a lot of people dumped
their stocks and the employees upper
management got a lot of bonuses the day
the day that the FDIC had to take over
so there's investigations there I told
you yesterday that I think absolutely
you should be investigated and what we
should do is make sure that anyone in
the management I don't care if it was
[__] dereliction stupidity or
whatever the thing that they need to do
is not be in banking anymore
that's right
we should end this country make sure
that anyone who [__] up a bank does not
[__] up another one now because now it
is that this this domino effect
has started over in Europe with some
weak Banks over there and it's going to
cause
um some consumer confidence problems
here but trust me when I tell you this
this is the most important thing and
every single elected official especially
Federal officials should be saying this
now Republicans are going to tell you
different because they want an
economical act they want a bank collapse
so they can blame it on the woke libtard
Biden and Hunter Biden's dick picks I'm
serious they're gonna try to do it
but this is not a Republican or Democrat
problem this is an American System
problem and we need to stand firm the
bite Administration and Janet Yellen
have made sure
to secure depositors money
so do not and and here's the the biggest
issue that is happening the biggest
issue is people who lose confidence in
community Banking and they start to move
their money to Big Banks
just because you move your money from
One bank to the other it doesn't mean
that's not going to hurt
so just be confident that your deposits
are protected you have competent people
that you elected to our government to do
competent things and to protect the
American people not the investors and
not the shitty management of these Banks
so if they have shitty management and
they have shitty investors that these
Banks [__] them protect the depositors
that's the most important thing that's
the insurance that we will not have a
bank collapse and any [__] out
there talking about a bank collapse or
trying to stoke at all an economic
collapse they are just trying to get
people to panic there's no reason to
panic just like there was no reason to
panic on gas prices or egg prices
or about railroad cars or airports or
airport safety
yes are there problems sure
but is it a panic issue absolutely not
so uh right now
um because the Dow is down it was up
yesterday but it's down back down today
um about where it was yesterday but it's
down about 600 points
okay
so
stay fast don't get too too crazy all
right
uh the next
the next item up to bid
oh my God this word woke
um you know we've been talking about it
here we can't figure out what they're
talking about they don't know what
they're talking about but there's a
special clip
of a republican columnist trying to
describe the word woke live on air and
um she can't do it it's hilarious we're
going to watch it we're going to watch
it and I'm probably going to watch it
more than once
Matt here today because uh it is it just
shows how ridiculous they are
when they're talking about wokism and
wokers and mother wokers
um in other news
there's a lot of [__] news to get to
today I mean a lot
it's a lot of stuff what do you want
from me
I was just trying
to give you what's going on out there in
the world
in in other news
uh Trump is suing DeSantis that's right
Trump is suing DeSantis so that's other
legal news that we have today here on
the Tony Michaels podcast here's what's
going on is in Florida there's a law
right and this is why I keep telling you
I don't believe Ron DeSantis is going to
get in this race I want him to trust me
I want him to the the sooner that Rhonda
Santos gets in this race the sooner that
Donald Trump can kill his political
career and Donald Trump knows that as
well and so does the Trump campaign they
need Ron DeSantis in the race now not
later they need him in now and the
reason why that is important
um in the narrative and our national
messaging is because we can encourage
them to fight each other because you got
to remember again I I'm gonna say this a
million times over the coming year is
that we are not in a general election
race we are in a Republican primary
cycle that is the cycle we're in right
that's what we're in ignore the
Democratic [__] all the [__] media
and all the lies on from from people who
want someone to to mount uh a run
against Joe Biden they're delusional
it's stupid it ain't gonna work it's not
it's not based in reality it's it's it's
ridiculous that anyone would challenge
This president's record and as an
incumbent president it's just not going
to happen
in a Democratic primary it won't try it
good yeah whatever you can quote your
polls and you can get butt hurt because
this person didn't end and that person
ain't in but it's delusional they say
I'm a cult member because I oh my God
you're simply for bite I'm not simping
for biting you dumb [__] I'm
simping for the truth and the truth is
is there's no chance in hell that
there's any other candidate out there
that is going to run against Joe Biden's
record and win in a Democratic primary
it's not going to happen you're the ones
who are the cult members if you believe
if you believe for a second for a second
that there's a person that is going to
be able to successfully challenge Joe
Biden's record in a Democratic primary
you are a dumb delusional [__] that
is right you're a dumb delusional
[__] and any mention of it any
mention of it only points out your
stupidity and how our [__] Civics
works and how our election system works
and how our two-party system works now
you can go on and on and on all day long
about how the two-party system is not
what we need and we need to change it
that's fine but you can't change it from
now until the 2024 election so good luck
so when you're saying these things about
um what the Democratic primary should or
shouldn't be or what it can be or who
should run blah blah blah yakity
smackity you're you're ridiculous you're
sounding ridiculous you sound like you
don't know what the [__] you're talking
about and you probably don't so from the
point of making sure that we take you
seriously on your commentary you should
probably shut the [__] up about stuff
that is not going to happen that doesn't
have the possibility of happening this
is like Jewish space lasers on the left
type [__] I'm telling you it's
delusional it's it's stupidity and
anyone who's anyone who's mentioning
this stuff out there at all at all does
not understand how our government works
how our Civics Works how our election
process works they don't understand how
the DNC Works they don't understand how
the delegate process works they don't
under they do not understand it
and if they do understand it and they're
still saying it they're gaslighting you
and they're lying to you that is what I
try to prevent I'm not trying to [__]
lie to you and give you some
misdirection so you feel all warm and
fuzzy inside [__] that [__] you need the
truth and you need to go out there with
the truth and use it to [__] prop up
our democracy because that's the only
thing that's gonna [__] save it
so now that we're past that point let's
talk about the race and the cycle we're
actually in which is the Republican
primary that's the race that's happening
that's the race that's going to continue
to happen and Donald Trump is going to
try to box out every [__] that
there is and I hope Rhonda santis gets
in and I hope Donald trusts Trump Burns
him down and pisses on the [__] ashes
of Ron desantos [__] him it is going to
be as glorious if that happens I don't
think Ron DeSantis gets in here's why
there's a Florida state law that
prevents a office holder a current
office holder from running for a higher
office and holding that office so Ron
DeSantis
when he announces that he's going to run
for president guess what he won't be
can you guess can you guess what Rhonda
Santas will have to resign as
why do you think I keep telling you that
Rhonda santis is not going to get in
this race not only is Rondo Santos not
ready to be a president of the United
States he's not ready to run in a
Republican primary and he's definitely
100 percent not able and and ready to
run against Donald Trump and his [__]
foaming at the mouth fascist cult it's
not gonna happen
it's it's it's not gonna happen
again I hope he does because if Ronda
Santos gets in this 2024 Republican
primary if he really truly does it will
ruin his political career it will crush
him he will not he will never see
another [__] office again more than
likely that is what I want
I want Donald Trump and Ron DeSantis to
go to Civil War inside the Republican
party and destroy each other and the
party in the process
no if you understand again if you're out
there and you you think that there's
going to be a primary Challenger okay
you think there's going to be a primary
Challenger
to Joe Biden and you don't understand
how it works
you don't understand how the Republican
primary works and how it we can use it
to our benefit
we're going to have a former president
who lost by 8 million votes be indicted
which looks like in not just one but
possibly two maybe three even four
jurisdictions in this country
that's only going to prop up his
campaign in the Republican primary which
is kind of weird and awkward but that's
just the way it is
it's a cult folks it's a [__] cult I
don't know what to tell you and there
are a bunch of fascists and they want a
an authoritarian figure to to turn this
into a dictatorship
I don't I don't know I don't know what
else to give you I I can't I can't
change that fact that's just the way it
is
so knowing that fact I know that Donald
Trump will secure the nomination because
of his indictments
now if
if we have
former president Donald Trump indicted
on several jurisdictions
and he prop gets prompted up and and
sent to the nomination with flying
colors on that fact
do you think Ron DeSantis ruins his
chance for for 2028. do you think he
ruins that by getting in the race and
happening vorgo his governorship in
Florida
because what is happening right now is
Donald Trump is suing the Ron DeSantis
campaign they're suing Rhonda Santa
saying you're actually running for
president but you're acting like you're
not running for president
so not only is is Donald Trump prepared
to fight Ron DeSantis on true social and
call him a pedophile and on the campaign
Trail apparently
um there's also evidence out there that
Donald Trump has already started uh
opposition research on Ron
Ron meatball tiny d desantos
now he's suing him in a court to try to
force him to resign his governorship
get him to commit to running for
president so that he can he can finally
strike and burn him down and we should
be encouraging it folks we should be
encouraging Ron DeSantis to get into
this race because he can't handle it
trust me on this he will not be able to
handle it he's not ready he's been doing
his book Tour on his wokism and he
doesn't know what woke means in this
country is sick and tired of hearing
them blame everything on wokeness oh gas
is hot woke eggs are high woke
Hunter Biden's woke laptop the banks are
woke it's really stupid [__] the
country's getting tired of it
and they'll continue to get more tired
of it now they're going to switch
they're going to switch you're gonna
watch him switch here they've been
trying this they've been trying this Dei
out diversity equity and inclusion okay
they've been trying that out right to
try to replace the word woke because CRT
worked really well it really was scary
critical race Theory
who the boogie man and it kind of died
off because everyone realized what the
[__] it was and realized that
Republicans were lying
now they're on the word woke and they
understand that the word woke is worn
because the country is smart to the
gaslighting
so now they're going to move to Dei
Dei is going to be the [__] that's
what you're gonna have to be scared of
going into the summer this D oh my God
diversity equity and inclusion
it's scary [__] I know it seems like
they're really
um desperate for an enemy because they
are these are invisible enemies that
they have
and it's not working out in their favor
I'm going to show you the video of this
uh right-wing columnist trying to
explain what woke means she has no
[__] clue she hadn't even looked it
up she ain't looked up the [__] in
our in our culture where the phrase
derives from
she doesn't even know that it means
black people
she has no [__] clue she has no clue
where where the origins of the word woke
in our culture derives from
no [__] idea
can you imagine a right-winger yelling
and screaming and gaslighting [__] to go
look up the truth give me a [__]
break
but I hope I hope that that Donald Trump
I'm cheering for him folks this is one
this is one time that you can cheer for
this [__]
I'm dead serious this is one time one
lawsuit that you can cheer for Trump on
and you should be cheering him on
to sue Ron DeSantis to get him to either
get in the race or stay the [__] out of
it one or the other we want him in the
race we want him in the race
we need him in the race it is very
important that we have him in the race
and it's important to have him in a race
so we can let them fight each other
they need to figure out that they're a
bunch of fascists
this country and people who vote based
on affiliation
because I've talked about this time and
time and time again that there's a lot
of people out there voting for
republicans and they don't even know
what the [__] they are
they don't even know what's going on
they're more worried about who's going
to throw the football on on Sunday who's
playing point guard tomorrow night and
who's going to be pitching yesterday
than they are about our [__]
government and our [__] society and
our country and our democracy that's
just the cold hard truth it's stupid it
doesn't make any sense it's
disappointing but that's just the
[__] truth
thank you
and we need to yell and scream and yell
and scream and be as loud as we can to
get their attention and one way to get
their attention is get Ron DeSantis and
Donald Trump to be battling it out in a
Republican primary in that race and in
that cycle and US encouraging it so yes
can we finally cheer for Donald Trump to
win a court case at so [__] lutely we
can
absolutely we can and we should be
excited about the outcome of the case
that Donald Trump is going to bring now
the unfortunate part is here that he's a
[__] bonehead and his lawyer and his
lawyers are even more boneheaded than he
is
so the likely outcome of this is that
Ron DeSantis
continues doing what he's doing but it
doesn't mean we can't draw a wedge
between him because of it
understand our national narrative
International messaging is super
important
very important very important another
story and some more footage I want to
show you speaking of fascists speaking
of a bunch of [__] fascist
boy these moglodytes are really coming
to um to Charlie Kirk's defense today
Charlie Kirk um trying to and give a
speech at a college at UC Davis I
believe is where it's at in Boston uh I
believe is is that right am I right am I
wrong about that I don't know
um
I I think that's where it is they're
claiming that antifa showed up can't
keep a shoot up and tried to tried to
use their freedom of speech and protest
to make it known that Charlie Kirk is it
is a fascist and he's gonna Sue he's
gonna no it's in Sacramento I'm
completely wrong that's I'm [__]
wrong it's in Sacramento I apologize uh
UC Davis is in Sacramento am I right
what or am I wrong
I might be wrong you know I'm trying to
be right
I'm trying not to do what Tucker Carlson
doesn't just [__] line like yeah sure
yeah do you see Davis hell that's in
Illinois I don't know
doubt me on it
no I I don't know I think I think it's
in Sacramento because and then there is
a a paper called the Sacramento Bee is
that right I think that's right too
um they said that Charlie Kirk uh is
calling for Trans people to be lynched
and he's gonna sue him he's gonna sue
them
sue him you [__] idiot let's do
Discovery let's do that let's do
discovery on rather Charlie Kirk once
to Lynch trans people because I said it
I I said it this morning I tweeted at
Charlie Kirk directly
hoping that I receive I'm waiting on my
season this is I tweeted Charlie Kirk
once
to Lynch trans people prove me wrong
prove me wrong prove me wrong Charlie
prove me wrong
antifa they're scared of antifa I'm
gonna show you these videos too
of antifa oh they're holding signs
they're holding signs that call Charlie
Kirk a fascist oh my God how scary
they're scared of Signs Now
um yes and so someone here on Twitch
says yes Tony UC Davis is near
Sacramento California see I I'm I get
there I get there I get around to it
sorry I was getting stories confused I'm
sure there's a lot of news this morning
what the [__] you want me to do I'm here
by myself today it's just me Gabe
Sanchez will be back tomorrow that's
right everyone has been asking where the
Mexican hunk of love is and he is still
on vacation he'll be back tomorrow I
actually believe he's in the air today
um so he's I think he's coming home
today but but from vacation but he won't
be back on the show until tomorrow
so tomorrow you'll see Gabe Sanchez here
so you're not you're not going to want
to miss tomorrow don't get off the air
now don't leave now just because Gabe's
not going to be here God damn it okay
stick around with me for crying out loud
I might not be as as handsome as he is
but you know I got some Talent too
so everyone stick around we're gonna be
right back we're gonna go through these
videos I got some footage to show you
right after this break
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment where
[Music]
back to the Tony Michaels podcast
show
oh baby
oh baby oh baby oh baby it's Wednesday
it's hump day
I got some videos to show you like I
said uh there's a uh I forget her name
now
he gives a [__] really it's um she's a
she's a um a republican Nazi
um
columnist yeah I called her that what do
you want me to do I told you I told you
that I wasn't [__] being hyperbolic
when I call them Nazis not just saying
that to say that [__]
last weekend I'm gonna keep pointing
this out there were [__] Republican
Nazis that showed up
to protest a drag show in Wadsworth Ohio
okay
Republican Nazis their daily wire Rio
America First Republican Nazis what do
you want from me
this is stuff that I can't help this is
stuff that they're doing when they're
being Nazis or gonna Nazi I just have to
[__] point it out
it's my job this is what I do
is point out the right far right wing
Nazis when they come about and they're
everywhere they're all in your
government they have ours behind their
names really frankly if you're still
identifying as a as a republican you are
a [__] Nazi that's right I don't give
a [__] if you're just voting based on
affiliation if you're willing to vote
for one of these [__] scumbags you
are one of these scumbags
what do you I I can't I can't just I
can't
change the facts
I don't get to [__] change them I
don't get to dictate them I just report
them and commentate on them
I'm here to give you the analysis of
what is going on and what is going on
there's a Republican Party
is going all in on the Nazi they're
leaning into the Hitler baby oh they're
leaning in I mean so much so that
they're giving Hitler salutes in Ohio to
protest a drag show I I'm telling you
I've showed this video I think three
times now once on my patreon on Sunday I
showed it yesterday I showed it Monday
thank you
I I can't I can't change what is
happening we're a bunch of Nazis dress
up in costumes matching uniforms and
costumes and go cosplay at a protest to
a bunch of Republicans cosplay is Nazis
to go protest a drag show because daily
wire or calling
calling for Trans people to be
eradicated and Charlie Kirk is mad that
people show up with signs protesting him
because he he is on the side of Daily
Caller and the Nazi Republicans
hmm
well that's just the way it is
I don't know I just commentate on this
so uh this reporter she can't Define
what woke is
she can't do it she can't do it which I
mean really honestly if you ever hear
someone say the word look you know
you think you think they would have
figured this out by now so Matt Walsh of
the daily wire that [__] Nazi rag
that's right I called the daily wire a
Nazi rag because it's a Nazi rag hey Ben
Shapiro send me a cease and desist it's
a Nazi rag
you're propping up Nazis in an example
is Wadsworth Ohio to go protest drag
shows because you think drag queens are
trans people for some [__] reason
you're really confused on facts and how
things work and how I didn't you should
really you should really maybe talk
to a trans person maybe you should talk
to someone who does drag maybe you
should talk to people in the lgbtq
community and not just talk at them you
[__] Nazi scumbags but listen to them
I don't know might might it might help
to know their experience might help to
know what they actually want out of life
it may be nice to know for you to know
why it is important that you give these
people Liberty might might change it
probably won't change your Nazi mind
at the daily wire and Charlie Kirk but
you know at turning points USA and daily
wire these Nazi Rags listen
I understand it might not change your
minds but
maybe if you just do a little bit of
that work you'll understand because Matt
Walsh went all around the world trying
to figure out what a woman was he had no
clue what a woman was do you remember
this what's a woman what's a woman
what's a what's a woman hey you hey you
lived hard what's a woman you get this
question a lot I watched David Pacman
even tried to handle this question and
he failed miserably that's right I've
watched the and David backman posted
that clip as if it was a great comeback
do you want to know what you say when
someone asks you
what is a woman
here's what you see here's your answer
I'll give it to you right here right now
here's your answer when someone asks
what is a woman are you ready do you got
your pen ready do you got your your text
act out so you can write it down or type
it up here it is
a woman is a gender that someone
identifies as
that's the answer
watch their [__] heads explode
a woman is a gender that someone
identifies as
it's also a word
that you don't know that [__]
definition of but
it is a gender that someone identifies
as that's where you start
okay it's really it's it's simple [__]
you don't have to get complicated you
don't you don't have to be you don't
have to be all [__] at woke
[Laughter]
and hacked and have to try to explain
someone else's experience
if your experience is not a trans
experience that's okay if your
experience is not an lgbtq part of that
Community is that that's not your
experience that's okay it really is okay
uh bypoc people of color if that's not
your experience it's okay you can still
listen people in the lgbtq community the
trans Community the people of color the
bipod Community they're not scared to
talk about these things they're not
scared to talk about their experiences
even with white people who look like me
and who look like you if you are white
out there they are not scared to talk
about these things to you they are not
scared to tell you their experience
open your [__] ears and listen to
them
that is one way that you can be a really
good Ally you do not have to have their
experience to listen to their experience
and to understand why their Liberty is
just as important as yours and why their
experience is just as important as yours
you [__] Nazi scumbags so do do
everyone a favor daily wire and turning
points USA you Nazi Rags do everyone a
favor
do you ever want a favor and just start
calling yourself Nazis it will be much
easier on all of us or or or
do the opposite of what Nazis are doing
that would be great because when you sit
at a table and eat dinner with one Nazi
if 10 people sit at a table and eat
dinner and yuck it up and have a great
time with one Nazi there are 11 Nazis at
that table that is just how it [__]
works
oh boy oh boy
it's gonna be a great day we're already
40 minutes in I haven't even showed a
video yet should I do some
self-promotion why we got everyone on
here I want to again thank everyone for
your support with the [__] em hats we're
I think I think we're gonna do hat week
once a month I don't know what we're
gonna call it but I think we're gonna do
hat week once a month where I give you a
promo code for the [__] em hats
um so if you didn't get your hat already
I'm gonna continue the promo into the
weekend so we'll go till I don't know
like Sunday at midnight or something is
when I'll shut off the promo code so if
you didn't get your [__] hat
yesterday no fear they're still 10 off
go to
hats.dtonymichaels.com or go to
thetonymichaels.com and scroll down and
hit the hat store button use the promo
code hats10 the promo code hats 10 and
get 10 off your order of [__] em hats
so go check them out there's all kinds
of different options I have the gray one
on today yesterday I had the red one
it's over here and then there's the blue
one down here a blue one is down here so
there but there's also there's pink
there's black there's uh snapbacks
there's fitted hats there's all kinds of
[__] em hats on the hat store so go to
the Tony michaels.com scroll down and
hit that store and while you're on the
Tony michaels.com please check out the
patreon we're doing crazy cool things
over there it's five dollars to join to
be a member of the [__] van and you
can buy other tiers you can spend more
for other tiers and other material uh
but it's it's kind of wide open right
now as new as patreon is we're having a
lot of fun we'll do a a um we'll do
another ask me anything uh probably
sometime this week
um in an afternoon sometime I believe
maybe an evening and then uh we have the
Sunday rant every Sunday that you can
come join us live and get in the chat on
the Sunday Sunday rant so again go to
the Tony michaels.com check out the hat
store and the patreon page let's do this
we need to get to these videos these
clips that I want to show you so we need
to surf the Tweety tweets and trendy
Trends let's start the countdown
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
the [__] list
welcome to the [__] list Roundup where
we round up all the Tweety tweets and
trendy trends
while they still exist over on elon's
Twitter and we're going to start with
this woke stuff oh my god
um so what's her name Bethany Mandel
Bethany Mandela that sounds like a
made-up name you know what you know why
um you remember in the Ohio Republican
Senate primary there was JD Vance
and Josh Mandel and then Trump got on
stage and said JP Mandel
is the person he's backing you remember
that he didn't know who the [__] what
the names were so this this name of
Bethany Mandel it sounds made up it
really does so Bethany Mandel is on the
rising
um and she was asking a simple question
this is [__] hilarious by the way oh
my God this is so funny
remember remember when I I just
um told you what the answer to Is when
someone asks you what what is a woman
Define woman what is a woman lived hard
and we we've watched this several times
and um even in Congressional hearings
where Republicans think it's a oh it's a
dig
when someone asked what a [__] what a
[__] woman is
yeah it's a gotcha question listen it is
a gender that someone identifies as it's
not complicated it is a gender that
someone identifies as it's really
[__] simple watch their heads explode
when you give them that answer no bill
wait [__] you [__]
you're you're just saying stuff I can't
and I can't compute just like in this
clip here this is [__] hilarious when
someone ever says those banks are woke
ask them a question here is the [__]
question you ask them it's really simple
Americans consider themselves very
liberal and probably fewer of them
consider themselves to be woke and so
you know when when we talk about you
would you mind the finding will because
it's come up a couple times I just want
to make sure we're on the same page
this is the perfect question this is not
a gotcha question now if you notice
Bethany here says in the beginning that
most Americans do not Define themselves
as liberal now that may be true I don't
know I don't know the data and I'm not
gonna dig up [__] stupid ass data and
stupid ass polls for you to hear that
aren't telling the [__] whole story
here's what I am going to do I'm gonna
make sure it's my mission my [__]
mission that people understand that they
are liberal you are a [__] liberal
you just don't know it you think it's a
scary word like woke no no it is not
scary to say you're liberal go go look
up the [__] word go look it up
and then tell me you're not liberal go
go look up the [__] word liberal and
then try to tell me that you're not that
it good [__] luck but watch
watch Bethany's meltdown here of trying
to figure out what she's been talking
about this whole time when she means
woke now remember you got to get the
context here because a lot of these
[__] idiots and like Bethany here
don't know the [__] historical
context of the word woke in our society
don't know what it was used for they
have no clue they have no clue
what the historical context of the word
evoke is and in political and social
movements and civil rights movements
they don't know what the word woke is
it's ridiculous that they haven't
[__] done just a little bit a little
bit of looking
on where the word woke in our society
in our political body where it derives
from
in recent history it derives from the
civil rights movement and here she is
talking to a black woman and a black
woman on air
does the simple thing I'm asking her the
question you know you've said this word
woke a few times and just so I
understand because I'm not I don't know
that we're on the same page to get on
the same page tell me what your
definition of woke is and what it what
what it means to you this is hilarious
watch this [__]
so
I mean woke is sort of the idea that
um
I
this is going to be one of those moments
that goes viral I mean
[Laughter]
says
this is one of those moments
moment that are gonna go viral
and the reason why is because she has no
clue what she's talking about
she has no clue what the [__] she's
talking about when she says the word
woke no [__] clue she doesn't know
the historical context she doesn't know
the actual definition of woke she
doesn't know the opposite of woke is
asleep
no [__] clue
she has no idea who her woke enemy is
she can't Define who are the wokers
right she's like
um see what I I didn't expect you to be
so unwoke and uh and be able to a form a
question that questions uh my beliefs
see this is the problem with fascist
and this is why you have to go at them
right that's why you have to [__] go
at them you have to go at them with a
Vengeance and you don't it's not
violence it's just uh intellect and just
you know cold hard facts it's not hard
to do it really isn't I mean you think
it was hard for this host to come up
with the question hey just so we're on
the same page because you keep saying
the word woke and I don't think you know
what it means you I and I don't think I
don't believe that you know what it
means you don't seem to know what it
means what does it mean to you
she can't even say what it means to her
and she had she's she's short-circuiting
so much that she understands that she's
on camera
and that this moment in this moment
because she has been on a Scourge and
the Republican party has been on a
Scourge to Define liberals and Democrats
and anyone who is their enemy and anyone
who does something that they don't like
as woke that they have lost the plot
line I've been telling you this for
weeks for weeks I've been telling you
they are losing the [__] plot line on
this word woke
it's unraveling
which is good we have to keep going at
this
we have to take back the word woke too
in in all in all reality
we have to be proud of the word liberal
proud of the word woke [__] them [__]
them they don't we are not gonna let a
bunch of Nazis shame us into not being
inclusive and having diversity and
having equity and equality and rights
and freedoms and not to oppress other
people's Liberty get the [__] out of
here we're not going to allow that to
happen just because a bunch of Nazis
want it to happen and just because this
[__] clown here wants to support a
bunch of Republican Nazis with their
[__] column or wherever she's writing
with the word woke when she doesn't even
know exactly what it means but she does
the reason why she's short-circuiting
do you wanna you wanna know the real
reason why I always give you the real
reason why the real reason why Bethany
year is short circuiting
is because
a black woman asked her this question
because my guess is Bethany knows the
historical context she knows what the
[__] rhetoric is she knows what the
dog whistle is she knows what the code
word woke means it means black people
it means black
okay it's racist when they say it
they are using it as a code word for the
n-word with a hard r
okay I don't I I don't know how else to
explain it when they're doing it but
that is the best way to explain
just every time you hear Rhonda santis
or any of these Republicans on Fox News
say the word woke they mean the n-word
with a hard r
that's what they [__] mean
that's what they mean
doubt me on this [__] you doubt me
remember when CRT or CRT ah CRT CRT this
and CRT that it's the enemy we have to
make sure there's no CRT in our math no
CRT in our schools no CRT in our
government they mean blackness
it's the [__] they mean
if you don't like me saying it [__] you
you [__] you if you don't like me saying
it piss off I'm fine with that you can
be mad at me that I'm telling the
[__] truth that everyone else knows
listen people of color know exactly what
these [__] are saying they know
exactly what the [__] they're saying
and if you would listen for a half a
second to people who they're talking
about
and use a derogatory terms about
if you would just listen to him for a
half a second you would understand what
the [__] they're saying and the reason
why Bethany short circuits here is
because she can't say it and the reason
why she can't say it is white people
here's what they do I'm telling you it
[__] always happens when you're with
some [__] racist white person done it
been there trust me you're in a
restaurant
they're gonna tell you a joke right you
know what joke they're gonna tell one of
them woke jokes you know what I'm saying
you know what I'm saying one of those
woke jokes
and the first thing they do before they
tell the joke is they look around
they look around to see
if there's any woke people in the
restaurant
you know what I'm saying you know what
I'm saying you [__] know what
I'm saying
and if there's woke people in the
restaurant I mean black
if there's black people in the
restaurant they won't tell that joke
with the hard r
they won't do it either that are like ah
we'll tell it later in the car you know
what I mean you know what I mean you see
you see that order you see them and
that's that's I've had it happen
and that is why Bethany here cannot say
the re what she really knows what the
word woke means she can't say it she
can't say it because there's one of
those wokers she can't say the joke she
can't tell the hard R joke there's one
of them hard art people here live on the
air
Bethany hey Bethany you're a [__]
racist you're that's right Bethany
you're a [__] racist and you're a
complicit in your racism
that's true oh Dustin here look at
Dustin hey Dustin when's the last time
you told a hard R joke in a restaurant
there buddy you [__] racist piece of
[__] you know exactly what the [__] I'm
talking about and you being in the
comments saying what is he talking about
and all capitals the only points out
only points out who you are you dumb
[__]
oh Dustin if we see you [__]
ah just like I see through Bethany okay
go ahead go ahead Bethany tell us tell
us what woke means uh let's see if she
can describe it here in the end I'm sure
she gets to it eventually is something
that's very hard to Define and we've
spent an entire chapter defining it
it is sort of the understanding that we
need to re totally reimagine and we re
reduce Society in order to create
hierarchies of Oppression
um
sorry I it's hard to explain in a 15
second sound bite it's really easy to
explain Bethany it's really easy to
explain what you mean you mean black
people and you mean the hard R that's
what you mean black people with a hard r
that is what the [__] you mean
that's it and if you don't like it if
you don't like it then change it
walk away from your stupid [__]
racist code words
they used to do this a lot trust me they
do it a ton I've been around I Oz bins
around some white people's like Dustin
over on Facebook
I know I know buddy
I know
I I I I grew UPS in those towns where
people would look around
to see if they could tell a hard R joke
you [__] idiot
I know I I know the tropes I know the
code words I know it
I certainly know it and Bethany here
doesn't understand that her own use of
the word woke
is a use of a trope
so [__] Bethany
[__] her and I'm glad she looks like a
fool and really honestly you should
continue to make these people look like
fools and
this is the perfect example of how to do
it so go watch this video share this
video around
Dustin
oh buddy oh Dustin he said what's a hard
R joke God damn maybe maybe the chat can
fill him in on what hard R means oh my
God you TR you truly are a dumb son of a
[__] I'm glad you show up here every
day Dustin here's the thing everyone
might might hate Dustin and Dustin you
know Dustin you know he comes here and
he says stupid [__]
laughs
and what I say might you know fly past
Dustin and he might not get what I'm
saying but because he shows up every day
folks because Dustin shows up every day
eventually eventually he'll be one of
those motherwokers he'll be so [__]
woke it won't even be funny you're gonna
be all right Dustin I promise you're
gonna be all right the chat's gonna fill
you in on what a hard R is and really
honestly anything that I say here Dustin
just go Google it just go use that
Google machine hell you can even use
DuckDuckGo if you think Google's woke
with a hard R if you think Google's woke
with a hard art just go use DuckDuckGo
you know they support white supremacist
over there so it'll be all right and I
bet even if you type in what is a hard R
joke
I'm I don't I almost I almost bet I
almost bet it'll spit out the right
answer I almost bet but I I would say
that you could talk to the smart people
in the chat this chat I don't know if
you know this Dustin but this chat is
filled is filled with very smart very
intelligent educated people not just not
just like book smart they're Street
Smart they're politically smart they're
smart on Civics that's why they come
here that's why they come here and hang
out
so yeah Dustin
maybe you should maybe go over to the
YouTube channel instead of on Facebook
Facebook is right in your mind maybe
that you haven't run into a hard R joke
and I know you have Dustin I know you
told one before surely you have man
[Laughter]
oh my God what in the [__]
[Music]
everyone everyone's wondering what hard
R means
woke with a hard iron that's what I'm
gonna call it from now on woke with a
hard iron just to um maybe that's the
messaging we need to get out there okay
what what do we want to go do next uh I
got some um let's see if we get some
other Clips to show you now let's see
what Clips do I have to show you oh yes
um there is a great news in Michigan
you know I don't talk about this a lot
but the AFL-CIO
um is posting a picture now this is a
celebration here in Michigan
where the Michigan State Senate has just
voted to repeal the right to work in
Michigan
um you know right to work negatively
affects labor
uh even even a lot of trump supporters
who were uh union members who voted for
Trump hate [__] right to work they
[__] hate it they [__] hate right
to work because it bangs up their Union
and it bangs up their their ability to
collectively bargain for their labor and
to trade their labor as a collective not
as an individual I don't know if you
know that in this country one of the
only things that um average Day Middle
America uh hard-working middle class or
lower class people have to trade in this
country they don't have capital A lot of
times they don't have money they can't
go and invest in SV svb Bank
or any other bank for that matter they
don't have money to buy stocks or invest
in a 401k or buy real estate they don't
have that kind of cash they just don't
have that Capital the thing that they do
have is their labor and they go into the
market and they trade their labor
for money
that's what we do and I think the
country lost sight of that up until the
2020 pandemic I think that's when it
really kicked in people's minds that hey
I'm actually doing the person that I
work for a favor
right they're not doing me a favor by
hiring me
I'm doing them a favor by trading my
labor to them for money
right A lot of people didn't really we
lost our way in this country with labor
we we didn't understand it we thought oh
man if you go down that company give you
a job they're doing you real good favor
even though they treat you like [__] you
should stay there and you should stick
it out because they're doing you a [__]
that [__] we are they are corporations
and and capital are not doing us a favor
when they hire us with our labor [__]
that [__] we are doing them a favor they
need our labor they have to have our
labor
uh so in Michigan they have voted to
repeal the right to work which has hurt
that state of Michigan and we know that
in the 2022 midterms
um Michigan was one state the Democrats
turned supposed to be this big red wave
guess what happens guess what happens
when working people show up guess what
happens when middle class people engage
in their democracy guess what happens
when the pro-democracy Coalition gets
out and votes for Representatives that
are serious about policy making you know
what happens you know what the [__] they
do they repeal [__] like right to work
to give power back to people who trade
their labor to corporations and it's not
a favor of the corporations to hire them
that's right
that that is where we need to get back
to in this country
I I know
um you know there's more scare or this
SVC and more Republican moglodytes out
there are really trying to work hard to
make you scared of your economy and your
bank to get you to go make a run on it
so that the economy collapses so they
have something to run on in 2024 but
it's not going to work
it won't work
it won't
and the reason why is because now more
than ever because we got out and we
engaged in our democracy our policy
makers that are serious that we elected
to be serious are doing serious things
for the American people is it happening
as fast as we want of course not it's
government
government in in a democracy especially
ours
is never fast enough
never works hard and fast enough
and really to to to undo a lot of the
the garbage like right to work in a lot
of these states that these fascists
Republicans have used to prop up
corporations and their investors and
their [__] donor class to donate to
their campaigns as opposed to [__]
work for the American people
foreign
people who are serious about undoing
these and we have to undo this [__]
we have to work hard just like the
banking regulations that Donald Trump
and the Republicans passed
to make sure that Community Banks can
end up like svb
we're gonna have to [__] work hard to
get these regulations back on banks not
not just not just for the depositors but
so the banks are held accountable so we
don't have this [__] problem
where we have to continually worry
about rather social media can cause a
goddamn economic collapse because
they're trying to get people to be
scared and lose confidence and make a
run on banks
and the Dow is steady now it's still
down but it's still steady
which should give you even more
confidence that this is being handled it
looks like
um
Powell is going to consider rather to
not raise rates that they were
considering raising
to pause rates for now
this is one of the problems with svb is
they were making bets on stupid [__]
based on facts that they knew
that they knew the Fed was going to
raise rates we'll just see if there was
insider trading so
it's all interconnected I don't know if
you know that like politics Society
banking economy it's all interconnected
stuff
it's a lot to get through oh God damn
do we do we have a video yet of um
um
[Laughter]
of Steve bannon's
um
uh Chinese National partner that he was
arrested on his yacht do we have footage
of him being him that he did I don't
think so
um you're you know here's the sad part
here's the sad part is is Steve Bannon
has lost another funder oh man that's
gonna be a damn shame damn shame that
Steve Bannon and Donald Trump's going to
lose another funder
minus touch points something out an hour
ago uh look here
um this is uh the new federal state of
Chinese is a group created uh by this
miles goo go girl I don't know I don't
know how to say it um and Steve Bannon
they were a major sponsor of the recent
seat back event the guy who just got
indicted
this is his this is one of his names
he's got several names apparently he
goes by Miles
um they he was indicted this morning on
fraud charge it's like a billion dollars
um by the sdny
now uh this same the same person in
Steve Bannon
um they the new federal state of China
oh my God you remember
this reminds me yeah uh someone laughs
smiles yeah that's what he goes by Miles
man I don't tell you what do you want
for me I can't
I can't um you know but
um
anyways anyways um
um so the um
the doj
indicts this game on a billion dollar
Front Scheme but this guy starts a group
with Steve Bannon and it's called the
new federal state of China and here is
the CPAC tweet
this is a CPAC tweet this isn't this hey
if you're wanting evidence out there
here's a CPAC treat thank you new
federal state of China for so your
support of CPAC and DC 2023
and being a prayer uh uh being a
partnering sponsor of our event oh yay
yay new federal state of China woohoo
China China China China China China
China
remember how they're always telling us
how China's band let me show you a clip
I need to retweet this and give credit
here uh to mightiest Dutch you know
we're we're affiliated with minus touch
we're on the Midas touch Facebook page
right now and if you're on Facebook
right now what you need to do
if you're on my dispatch Facebook page
is go follow our page two at the Tony
Michaels let me show you a clip though
of Steve Bannon
claiming that someone you'll know
is
um
is on the hawk the China okay
let's see I don't want to play that clip
there's a person on Twitter that puts up
clips
and they're doing it from their TV
they're like recording it and the sound
is [__] horrible okay here's on Steve
Bannon show now he did it on uh Tim
pulls podcast dude but here's on Steve
Madden show he doubled down on it let's
listen up crony capitalism Elon Musk and
by the way when we cut him off he went
begging he went begging the CCP and
that's why they have the joint venture
in Shanghai the Tesla which is 100 of
his value right this guy lives on
government contracts and taxpayer
subsidies okay it's all we're gonna get
Joe Allen in here for a second
transition Elon Musk once again brother
uh I'm smart enough to tell you no to
your face and I'm evil enough to be able
to expose you as a running dog for the
greatest enemy this nation's ever had
you are War profiteer you're in you're
sleeping with the Enemy brother and
you've been doing it because all you
you're not an American nationalist
you're not even an American
all you are is a globalist okay a
globalist and you will go where
everybody anybody writes you a check and
you wouldn't you would take it from
Adolf Hitler himself because you're
taking it from people that are as bad as
Adolf Hitler the murderous regime of the
Chinese Communist party which you
praised on their 100th anniversary let
me bring in
there you go there's Steve Bennett who
he's attacking I don't know if you know
this guy or not I don't know if you've
heard of him
um who he's attacking there is Elon Musk
he's attacking Elon Musk for taking
money from anybody even Adolf Hitler
listen
I'm telling you I'm telling you that
that Adolf Hitler 100 would give Steve
Bannon money and Steve Bannon would ask
for more money as soon as Adolf Hitler's
check cleared he would be asking for
more money but isn't it funny isn't it
funny
that this Chinese National that Steve
Bannon was arrested on his yacht his
elitist yacht is now indicted on a
billion dollar fraud charge
seems kind of weird and Steve Bannon has
a group
that he started with this guy that gave
sponsorship to CPAC
huh seems kind of funny to me you know
Elon Musk told us to vote Republican
Steve Bannon seems to be a republican he
seems to be a Nazi he went to the Nazi
rally it's or the CPAC I mean his money
went there
Steve bannon's money went there he went
there too you remember he was knocking
on Fox News at the Republican uh rally
the Republican Nazi rally at CPAC just
this last one
uh Jan says here on YouTube Hitler would
be proud of both of them nah you know
and Jan I have to disagree I think
Hitler would be totally disappointed in
these nincompoop Nazis I really think he
would I I don't know I don't think
Hitler would be proud I think he would
be really um he would be real
he would be really disappointed in these
[__] boops
oh man thanks for your comment Jan okay
so let's go back to the um because I
have some pictures to show you here I
want to show you who this uh this
Chinese National is that has been
indicted this morning the one that the
one that uh Steve Bannon was on his
elitist yacht and has been taking money
from him for a long time so we have let
me let me pull up some pictures of him
here I don't know if maybe you'll
recognize
um this guy
Maybe not maybe maybe you won't uh maybe
you won't recognize him I mean I have
plenty of pictures here of him with
Steve Bannon
um let's see if I can pull up some
pictures
of him with some other folks because
there's there's apparently
he apparently goes to to Mar-A-Lago a
lot
um I don't know if uh if anyone knows
where Mar-A-Lago is
um God damn I thought that was and there
was more pictures of course there's this
one I don't know if you can see this
here's the guy right here 's a gang
question here's a guy that was the night
is more does it look like they're gonna
kiss
this I don't know man this looks this
looks suspiciously sexual
I don't know I think we need to start
some legislation somewhere to prevent
this kind of [__] from happening
of course I'm joking of course I'm
joking calm down I'm pointing out that
they like to do that kind of [__]
down there was I'm trying to find a
picture of
um this guy and Rudy Giuliani where in
the [__] is it what the [__] is going on
here
God damn it
I I had it earlier see I don't know if
you guys know this but when I when I do
my uh
my show when I'm I'm figuring out what
I'm gonna show you I just retweet this
stuff did you know that
so it's easy to find I I gotta have it
easy to find I gotta have it right at
hand that's why I like using Twitter
because I don't have to load up graphics
and do all kinds of it's why why you're
looking at it on the internet too right
and you want to see where I'm finding it
right why am I gonna [__] pull up
make a graphic give you the source when
I can just show you the actual source
that I'm getting it from right here live
on the air you know what I mean
I mean in this day and age we have the
technology I can just pull it up I don't
have to I don't have to I don't have to
uh I don't have to be all fancy and and
spend hours and then something change
it's just you know
um here Mueller she wrote uh has the um
has the headline here uh breaking
um this guy again you Wing you I don't
know I don't know how do you say it uh
Gwen gee I don't know I don't I I barely
speak English [__] uh so I'm
definitely gonna get this name wrong has
been indicted he's the guy that owns the
out the Bannon was arrested on here's a
picture of him hey look we're best
buddies now so there's another picture
of them that's the guy there
um but um
here's here's the picture of the yacht
here we go there's a picture of that oh
look they're yucking it up on the yacht
and there's Steve Bannon on the aunt
where he was arrested oh boy these um
you know I wonder if this guy's ever
been to Epstein's Island I'm just saying
maybe someone should check the flight
records maybe you could get uh the manga
trolls
and you get the Maga trolls to check the
flight records see if this guy was ever
on Epstein's Island
I'm just saying I don't know I I'm not
saying I know that that's not what I'm
saying what I'm saying is you check you
should ask all the my controls that have
access to Hunter Biden's um
laptop you should ask them if it's on
there if his name's on there uh here he
is at Mar-A-Lago here's the same same
dude same dude at Mar-A-Lago I don't
know if you know where Mar-A-Lago at do
you know who owns Mar-A-Lago you know
what kind of parties they have there uh
there he is at Mar-A-Lago uh let's see
let's see what else what else this gay
who else this guy's taking pictures with
and did it
God damn it I'm trying to look for the
picture he loves Rudy Giuliani
apparently
and it's probably at Mar-A-Lago where he
met a lot of these folks you know what I
mean
that's probably where it was at well I
can't find it
I'm probably lying
oh boy
oh boy uh some more footage that I want
to show you
um and some more video I want to get
back to some video here
because we're going to get to the Trump
lawyer video I promise on Ari milber's
show holy [__] holy [__] I hope this is
his good lawyer too
this is supposed to be his best lawyer
I'm not [__] you that's that's what
they claim what do you want from me
again I can't I I don't make the news I
just commentate on it right what do you
want me to do
I can't I can't change what it is I can
only tell you what it is uh and I'll
tell you what this is I'm here is um
here's Jack prostate it's [__] dumb
[__]
um
he's really upset that he's really upset
that people were holding signs and
protesting Charlie Kirk oh my God
they're calling in an Insurrection at UC
Davis what the [__] are you talking
about an Insurrection see this is this
is the problem is uh these these right
Wingers these mongolites don't know
definitions to words they don't know
what an Insurrection is they don't know
what a riot is they don't know what the
word protest means this is why they have
issues of figuring these things out but
I said fascist
shall not be comfortable we should not
let fascist be comfortable and Charlie
Kirk was speaking at UC Davis
in Sacramento California
guess what
some people showed up made sure that he
was not comfortable
you know made him feel a little bit
uncomfortable here's footage of it
by the way this is the footage that they
claim is the the bad footage right this
is the footage that you shall not see
because if you see this if liberals see
this footage they'll know the truth
about the protesters holding signs
outside you can see it with your own
[__] eyes right are you watching the
same video I'm watching because this is
the video they're posting that says they
had an Insurrection and they were
attacking the building watch they're
holding signs outside watch
oh no oh no
they're getting really close to the door
at that sign holy [__] they're getting
really close to the door at that sign
God look how cool close they are to the
door at the sign oh my God oh my God
what what shall what shall they ever do
maybe they'll lock the doors or
something to make sure that sign doesn't
get in the building that pesky little
sign oh my God
oh oh my God oh my God they kicked a
window in oh oh how fragile oh look
Charlie Kirk's life is at risk because
they broke a window oh my God Glass
Broken Glass are you serious it's it's
almost like they're gonna crawl through
this and trespass will they trespass
into this building let's see
oh
okay
oh poor Charlie Kirk poor Charlie Kurt
there's broken glass in the lobby
[__] him [__] him and if your man if
you're mad that they cause property
damage be mad about it and if you're mad
that that these people were holding
signs be mad about it be mad about it
but don't be upset that these [__]
fascists are getting really
uncomfortable to spread around their
hate and their lies
they're spreading hate and lies which is
putting people's lives in danger listen
to me listen to me Nazis
Nazis in matching uniforms showed up in
Wadsworth Ohio
and we're giving the Hal Hitler sign
saying Lynch them they were calling for
them to be lynched hang them with a rope
is what they were saying hang them with
a [__] rope
so excuse me excuse me if I'm not really
worried about a little bit of property
damage that someone kicked in a [__]
window because Charlie Kirk is is
promoting
the turning points USA and daily wire is
promoting the eradication of a group of
people in this country and encouraging
Nazis to go go protest and chant hang
them with a rope you [__] get
it straight in your minds
get it straight in your [__] minds
stop making oh well we can't Tony we
can't have people kicking in when that
looks really bad okay it may look bad
but I don't give a [__] you know what
looks really bad when Nazis show up in
Ohio under under the the [__]
direction of turning points USA and
daily wire and they're chanting hang
them with a rope
got it
do you got do you know do you do have
you read a book
on 1930s and 1940s Germany
have you read it
have you read what what the what the f
what the [__] happened
just a little bit you don't have to read
the whole story you'd have to know every
facet of every single little detail
it is important that we show these
people that you you espousing your views
and using your freedom of speech shall
come with consequences and those
consequences may be that you may not be
comfortable living in this country
because we will not tolerate intolerance
it is not gonna happen
and should the people that were kicking
in Windows be prosecuted for property
damage sure whatever I don't give a [__]
I'm sure they don't give a [__] either
oh if you think they gave a [__]
if you think they gave a [__]
about if they're going to be prosecuted
for kicking in Windows I bet they
weren't kicking them in
am I promoting them kicking in Windows
that's not what I'm saying
that's not what I'm saying at all just
like just like Charlie Kirk is not
calling for people to be lynched
[__] out of here with that nonsense
fascist shall not be comfortable we do
not have to tolerate your intolerance
and we do not have to promote your
[__] hateful rhetoric
because because you want to feel
comfortable because you want to practice
your freedom of speech without
consequence [__] you [__] you you're
encouraging Nazis to go out there and
protest drag shows because you think
that drag queens are transgender people
which they are not I mean they can be
but you're not understanding what this
is
and it is time to push back on these
[__] it is time to make them
uncomfortable to speak in public or say
what they're saying yes it's time
it's time because history history always
repeats itself Susan says it here we're
in the same boat as 20s 30s Germany
that's important I like how you frame
that up Susan 20s and 30s Germany not
30s and 40s because 20s and 30s Germany
is a little different than 30s and 40s
right it's a little different it's a
little different the reasons why
now I have to disagree with you a little
bit on the same same boat
these are the same tactics that are
being used but we are not in the same
boat our system of government is
completely different our country is in a
completely different standpoint than
what Germany was after the first World
War
we have a much stronger fabric of
democracy and equity in this country and
diversity in this country why do you
think people are showing up at UC Davis
because that [__] fascist Charlie
Kirk is speaking at it encouraging Nazis
to go protest at drag shows and call
people to be lynched
uh Robin says look at your messages Tony
uh Robin I know the problem but I can't
I can't solve it here at this moment so
um we're gonna try to get the the
problem that's in the chat fixed after
the show I just and I'm I'm the only way
I don't I don't have the ability to to
fix it right now
so Charlie Kirk here's his here's his
little tweet let me show it to you oh
here's his tweet because this is the
Sacramento Bee the sac b as it's called
online
um their headline was another fascist
speaker is coming to UC Davis how should
the community respond
Charlie Kirk has called for the lynching
of trans people a comment that should
warrant the cancellation of a speech
engagement at UC Davis and Charlie
Kurtz's
this is defamation and libel oh always
crying always crying about their freedom
of speech why are you so afraid why are
you so afraid to lie and then have
people tell little white lies about you
you [__] [__] you goddamn [__]
ass [__] Charlie Kirk
he says we will sue unless it is
corrected left wing Rags like the sack B
are allowed to plant form lies against
conservatives and get away with it time
for lawfare
oh Charlie Charlie so I tweeted at him
like directly I didn't [__] take an
image of this I tweeted at him quote
tweeted Charlie Kirk wants trans people
lynched prove me wrong do it prove me
wrong that he that he doesn't want him
lynched do it come on Charlie send me a
cease and assist you little [__] let's
go to war law fairs you God Warfare law
fair whatever let's do it let's do law
fair [__] let's do it I ain't
got near as much money as you
but I'll I'll fight you I don't give a
[__] I'll fight you in a court let's do
it I'm not scared of Courts I've been in
court before I've been in much more
serious Court than you will ever dream
of that they will ever put your your
privileged ass in Charlie Kirk you piece
of garbage what a piece what a [__]
[__] oh it's definition and libel oh
I'm gonna sue you you goddamn [__]
send me a season assist because Charlie
Kirk wants trans people lynched prove me
wrong prove me wrong get in the comments
tell me why he doesn't
see when you when you turn it around on
them when you turn it around on them it
really [__] them up that's why I keep
telling you man this is going to be the
hottest political show that there is on
the market it really is gonna be there's
not gonna be anyone that's gonna hold
the candle there's just not no one no
one is going to go after the messaging
rank I am it's just not gonna happen and
I mean we've been through this that yes
there's Hal Sparks he does a really good
job there's Richard Ojeda he does a very
good job at knocking these people
but there's not anyone that doesn't like
me they just don't and they won't
so [__] them okay let's um I can show
you more clips of this UC Davis thing in
this Charlie Kirk thing but it's more
the same it's more there's another video
of one of these Charlie Kirk supporters
trying to attack the protest crowd and
tagonize the progress protest crowd
that's holding a [__] sign
um and then they have to chase the guy
away with umbrellas I'm not [__] you
that's a [__] video uh but you know I
want to move on here
and the reason why I want to move on is
because I want to get to this Trump's
attorney on Ari melbert oh my God have
you seen these clips have you seen this
[__] this [__] guy it's the Stormy
Daniels case now there's there's four
investigations now there was well five
but there was there was three really
strong investigations into Donald Trump
up until this morning that we knew now
this morning there's four and the first
one was because we've already had him
his his organization his business
has already been criminally charged and
convicted of 17 counts of fraud criminal
fraud now they're going to pay 1.61
million dollars uh in fines now the
Civil side of New York is their their
tis James is going to take care of the
Trump organization on the Civil side
but the criminal or the criminal
investigations currently that are
ongoing is the one in the Manhattan DA's
office where Michael Cohen probably
right now as we speak is talking to the
grand jury answering the grand jury's
questions on the criminality of the of
the hush money payment that was paid to
Stormy Daniels from Donald Trump okay
and that's and that's what this
interview from Ari melber was with that
attorney and you know what you know what
it's been said in the media that this
was Trump's best like he's the good
attorney you know like he's the good one
he's the one that's oh man if if you
compare Christina or Christina Bob or
Helena Abba those are the bad ones this
is the good one holy [__] if this is the
good one I can't wait I can't wait for
him to get into court to defend Donald
Trump it is it is it is laughable
um so I'm going to show you some of
these clips
um from Ari melbour show the beat
on Trump's good attorney
stick around don't don't go anywhere
we're gonna go over these clips don't
[__] sit tight
we're gonna go through these clips in
the last half hour of the show don't go
anywhere
we'll be right back
right after this
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product part in blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
foreign
[Music]
we're gonna watch these clips where the
hell do you [__] go there's
like 1500 people in total did you know
that that we have like 15 to 1800 people
watching this show live every day did
you know that
I'm not [__] you I wouldn't [__] you
you are my favorite turds I would not
[__] you I'm telling you there's 15 1800
people watch this show live every
[__] day
and there's thousands more that watch it
on replay and thousands more after that
that listen to it on podcast directories
so it's super important if you want to
listen to it on audio that you go
download it on Apple Spotify and Google
any any of your pod directories anywhere
it's on there
it's on there now I will I will say
I will say that that here's the thing is
that you should go download it on all
the directories it helps out but what
you should do is come watch live on
YouTube
at the Tony Michaels pod
uh just just search the Tony Michaels
podcast or you can go to the Tony
michaels.com and you can find all the
links there
for the YouTube channel and if you know
what go subscribe to the up wire as well
go subscribe to the up wire as well
you know we were there during um
when we were when we were on our
suspension
we are on our suspension
uh MJ and Margie I just uh I took care
of yours too so I don't know if that
helps I don't know if it's gonna help
let me know if it helps but I think
YouTube's broke with the moderator in
the chat thing now they've got a new
feature and I think that might have
broke it so I don't know I'm gonna try
I'm gonna try I promise I'm trying I
promise I'm trying
um also also go follow us on Twitch you
can watch us on Twitch a lot of people
like the chat over there on Twitch as
well and follow us on Facebook at the
Tony Michaels
1500 to 1800 people
live
every day you know what we need to do we
need to get up to like 10 to 20 000.
that's what we need to do I think we can
do it what do you think I think how how
[__] amazing would it be
if we had 10 000 people 15 000 people in
the chat
God damn I'd have to slow it down to
like 20 seconds 30 seconds we'd have to
we'd have to have a whole nother round
of moderators especially if we have a
problem like we have today
the marginal one I'm talking about other
people may not but the mods the one I'm
talking about
Hellboy give the minds love today
because they're having
they're having issues in the chat I
think it's YouTube though I don't think
it's
I don't think it's a problem over here I
think it's YouTube
I think it's YouTube
to be quite honest
um this guy is such a good propagandist
thank you and I I take that as a
compliment this is pro-democracy prep
again to hear on the Tony Michaels
podcast you goddamn right you goddamn
right this is pro-democracy propaganda
for sure
we we are our foundation is truth and
Liberty here on the Tony Michaels
podcast and it is 100 grade A
pro-democracy propaganda from the
rushland ball of the left as I've been
called yes so I mean if you're trying to
knock me okay that's good
okay let's get to these uh Ari melbour
Clips God damn this is one of my
favorite here let's play this one first
uh it's about two minutes long not here
and this is the one where the the Trump
attorney tries to grab Ari melber by the
receipts
again what do you want from me I can't I
don't get to make this [__] up I'm just
I'm just here to commentate on it he
literally tries to grab Ari melber by
the receipts you can't make this [__] up
it is a thing that happens in trumpland
watch this dip [__] this is we'll just
start let's go if all of what you say is
true it is then why was Trump hiding it
and lying about it at the time and I'll
play that for your response he lied
about it we all know that take a look
[Music]
okay so and because the audio is a
little crazy here and the reason why is
because this video is from 2018 I
believe
2017-2018 is when this this audio is
from When Donald Trump was a president
he was actually on Air Force One when
they were asking him this and the Press
Corps on Air Force One was asking him
here's the question did you know about
the 130 000 payment to Stormy Daniels
and they're talking about the 130 000
payment that Michael Cohen made to
Stormy Daniels now listen to his
response I'll I'm gonna dub it over here
and let you know because the audio is
tough on this video meaning the original
audio from the from the the video that
the reporters were taking on the plane
he said no no no he does not know about
it the reporter is going to ask then why
did Michael Cohen make those if there is
no truth to her allegations let's can
let's listen
Trump says well you'll have to ask
Michael Cohen
Michael Cohen is my attorney now what
Donald Trump is doing here and his
attorney is wise to this he's trying to
do the whole attorney-client privilege
thing
and you'll see the argument from the
attorney in the end which is a really
flimsy argument for crime by the way
it's a [__] it's all horrible oh
horrible
horrible horrible argument for crime
but they're trying to use the
attorney-client privilege and I don't
want to break a con as if Trump doesn't
like to break contracts Trump's never
broke a contract in his entire life
that's the argument that he's gonna make
but but listen to what Trump says here
at the very end
sorry you'll have to ask Michael now
here's Trump's new attorney okay so
remember Trump was talking on air force
one about his attorney who made the
payment to Stormy Daniels which was
Michael Cohen
uh Michael Cohen by the way just a piece
of news so everyone knows Michael Cohen
I think currently right right now let me
check um Michael Cohen I think is right
now taking questions from the criminal
grand jury that is doing a probe in this
investigation into the into the illegal
payment that Donald Trump made through
his campaign to Stormy Daniels okay now
rather this is illegal or not on a
federal level I you know I'm not sure
that's it's the Manhattan D.A that's
going after him here uh in this case
because it's a bribe
but let's listen to what Donald Trump's
new attorney I'm sure he's so much so
much better than Christina Haba this is
the good one that they claimed he's the
good lawyer let's listen to what the
good lawyer has to say about the lie
that Donald Trump just told
that is that's what you're going to
consider a liar a lie to me is something
material under oath in a procedure
okay so this guy doesn't understand that
um we can hear lies we know what the
definition of lie is and we know that
Donald Trump's a liar he's gonna guess
he's gonna try to Gaslight our immobile
here I don't know if you know uh this I
don't watch Ari a lot I I've seen Ari
before I've watched his show the beat
some a little bit most of it in Clips
because that's what I gotta watch stuff
in there's so much [__] out there and
there's so much media that you gotta
watch the [__] in Clips you can't hardly
watch the whole thing you just can't do
it
um now Ari is a lawyer that's what Ari
is he's also a news personality over
there at MSNBC he's had this show the
beat for a long time I think four or
five years at least that Ari's been
doing this show
um Ari also is a very uh he's a
connoisseur of hip-hop he uses hip-hop a
lot and he uses hip-hop lyric quotes
um in his material and in his commentary
okay
um so I know who Ari melber is I'm I'm
well versed in Ari melbert
and I cannot believe that this [__]
attorney went on his show and does not
know who Ari melber is that he thinks he
can Gaslight Ari melber into into
telling him this is not a lie because
it's not under oath watch what Ari does
perjury I said a lot yeah but that's not
a lie that's that's not a lie here's why
it's not a lie that's not a lie his
wife's not alive could you did you know
now here's the moment here's the moment
this is hilarious I'm gonna back it up
here Ari's like whoa whoa that ain't a
lie what the [__] are you talking about
that anyway I heard a lie I heard you
say one thing and then him saying
another on tape and he was lying but
watch how he tries to grab watch this
this is this is this is how it's gonna
go
right in this moment this this is
this is the foreshadowing of how this
case is going to go for Donald Trump in
court folks
I know it feels like oh this is great
this is a great clip this is fun but if
this attorney is the one who represents
Trump in court which I hope it is this
is the foreshadowing of what is going to
happen in court because watch what this
attorney tries to do he tries to grab
away Ari's paper he tries to grab Ari
melber by the receipts watch why that's
not a lie his wife's all right did you
know about this did you
know about this no I don't but we don't
need that here's what why
I don't know we don't need it look at
Ari's face later let me make it bigger
look at Ari's [__] face he's like
what the [__] he's Ari's like I don't I
don't I think we need the facts I think
we can go with the truth here uh you
[__] gaslighting fool
again
don't watch Ari melber every day I don't
watch him a lot
I don't the most I've seen Ari is when
he's had Peter Navarro on his show
um and he's done uh you know the little
Tango with Peter Navarro and that tree's
in this piece of [__] and basically
telling Peter Navarro you broke the law
you people are break you were trying to
overturn the government and Navarro's
like well I wouldn't exactly call it
that
I wouldn't exactly call it a coup I mean
what's the definition of a coup are he
but again I cannot believe that this
attorney went on Ari Melbourne's show
and here here's another fact that you
may not know
is that not only is Ari melber a lawyer
and he's a very smart person Ari is not
dumb okay
um and he he knows how to argue because
he is a lawyer and he's also a media
personality so he knows how to use the
camera the microphone and the the
interview process uh to steer his show
that's any good host knows how to do
that now
the other fact that maybe this attorney
does not know is that Michael Cohen has
appeared on Ari melbour's show dozens of
times probably I'm sure it's at least at
least eight or nine at least I'm not
sure the exact amount but Michael Cohen
goes on Ari's show a lot
which only means that Michael Cohen is
very familiar with Ari melber and Ari
melber is familiar with Cohen and so are
their producers
so it's not like you can [__] lie to
Ari melber even about what Michael Cohen
is or isn't saying
this is this is I can't even believe I
cannot even believe that this attorney
went on his [__] show to be quite
honest with you and all this is there
was only one person that was watching
this that this attorney was performing
for only one only one and that's the
other thing that Ari melber knew
that's the other thing that Ari knew
here is that he could get this attorney
on his [__] show and Donald Trump
would watch from front to back
he would watch from front to back and
this again this is foreshadowing because
Watch What Happens here it's not a lie
yeah because it was a confidential
settlement so if he acknowledged that he
would be violating the confidential
settlement so is it the truth of course
it's not the truth was he supposed to
tell the truth he would be in violation
of the agreement if he told the truth
so there there's a little oh there's Old
Joe's
there's his justification
is that he would have broke the look
it's not the truth of course it's not
the truth what is the opposite of the
truth then Joe
what is the opposite of the truth
if it's not a [__] lie okay
are you serious
so you just told us it's not a lie and
now you're going to tell us that it's of
course it's not the truth
the [__] are you are you this is this we
are in such a weird [__] timeline and
this again this is supposed to be the
good attorney that is defending Donald
Trump this is the this is the best he's
got
now the argument that he's trying to
make here is that there was a
confidentiality agreement between Stormy
Daniels and Donald Trump and if he would
have said anything about that in the
outside the confidence of that agreement
then he would be breaking that agreement
which is the truth the problem is is
that you cannot you cannot use
confidential agreements to hide crime
and you can't just like you can't use
the attorney-client privilege to hide
crime that's not something you can do in
other words Donald Trump could not
commit crime in the form of a bribe and
then use a confidentiality agreement
around that bribe
to make sure that no one talked about
the crime of the bribe you follow me
you do follow me right
and that's the argument that they're
going to make
you can I I can already see it playing
out this is the argument that they're
going to make especially if this is the
attorney that he didn't he it was a
confidential agreement she agreed to it
he agreed to it the confidentiality he
couldn't tell the truth
it doesn't matter
just like we know in the in Eastman's
case with the Cheeto dust kangaroo coup
from from Judge Carter out in California
who ruled that the Eastman emails could
be given
outside
of the attorney crime client privilege
because they were in coordination to
commit a crime
the same way as you can't hide crime
with a confidentiality agreement it's
not a thing that I mean you can you can
try and Trump and Cohen tried Cohen paid
the price already going to federal
prison
You Can't Hide crime with a
confidentiality agreement you just can't
do it but let's let's hear more of this
argument that they're going to make in
court and this is delicious folks
because this shows you their argument
and shows you how truly [__] Donald
Trump is so by him doing that by him
doing that he it was abiding by not only
his rights but Stormy Daniels it seems
like we're drawing some blood here
because you're having a strong reaction
oh Ari melber and again I don't
understand how this this guy didn't
just look Ari melber up I mean just just
figure out his background
watch a few clips of him and Peter
Navarro understand that Ari melber is in
close contact with Michael Cohen who is
a witness in this case and has had him
on his show several times to interview
him about this specific case
how in the [__] don't they know this are
you [__] kidding me and Ari Melbourne
says it looks like we're drawing blood
because you're having a strong reaction
here which Ari knows he's got this guy
on edge and he knows he's gonna poke the
bear here and get the bear to sniff up
the cocaine and commit murder watch this
he did lie about it and in a
confidential settlement you can easily
say no comment or I'm not getting into
it that's right that's right he didn't
have to lie about it he could just say
no comment I can't get into that because
that's an ongoing investigation or
there's there's reasons why I can't talk
about that issue you could have said
that he didn't have to lie but watch
this and the reason why I look at this
he says no no I didn't know about it he
did know about it didn't he you know but
here's the thing I don't know the timing
of that video I really don't and I'm not
trying to please April 28th but I don't
know the time so here here now he's
going to do the timing thing right this
I'm telling you I'm telling you folks oh
my God this is gonna go so well
so well in court for the prosecutors
this attorney this attorney says I don't
know when that clip was from this is the
[__] attorney that is supposed to be
representing Donald Trump in this case
and he has no clue
no clue he has not even done enough
[__] enough [__] Research into the
case that he's going to defend Donald
Trump on to know when Donald Trump said
something on camera about the case
what the [__] are you [__] [__]
me
are you this is the good lawyer this is
the good one this is the one that
everyone's been painting and hey this is
this is the guy this is the guy that's
gonna you know he's out you know that
ABBA and that Christina Bob they're dumb
[__] but this one's the good one are
you [__] me
who who thinks this guy's a good lawyer
now watch it gets even it gets even more
in the weeds here on the dates watch
this I have to do in relation to the
timing of the other video where he was
speaking to microphone what was the date
of that other video do you know
so now he doesn't know he's asking Ari
melber for legal advice
this guy's asking the guy who produces a
show a TV show hey man do you know the
facts in this because I sure don't
how well do you think this is gonna go
for Trump if this guy's defending him I
I mean I'm I'm open this guy defends him
I hope Donald Trump has already made
sure to get some sort of retainer here
I hope he gets some sort of retainer
here to make sure I want this guy to
defend him in the Jack Smith case too
how about you I owe this guy defends him
everywhere the Georgia case the Jack
Smith case the documents case the Trump
media case that is now being
investigated by the FBI
into laundering eight million dollars of
Russians money that's right there's a
new criminal investigation being opened
up into Trump and his and his Media
Company
in the SPAC
which is the merger of his company and
another company to try to go public
to try to raise one point or one point
so many billion dollars
of funding for his Trump media
apparently eight million dollars came
from the Caribbean to be laundered for
the Russians I hope this guy defends him
in that case too because listen to this
there's more we're not at the end here
there's more of this stupidity let's
listen uh yeah we have the Cohen
recording this was around the 2016
campaign pre-november so that was 2018
later uh the original conversations were
in the uh fall of 2016. yes sir so
um
so Ari has to give him the dates here I
mean Ari's got him written down but this
guy doesn't have any clue what the [__]
okay keep going obviously he knew about
it but what he decided to do was not
violate confidentiality and provision of
that oh yeah which was the right thing
to do yes that is the right thing to do
it is the right thing to do to have a
confidentiality agreement to cover up a
criminal bribe that and a break campaign
Finance law that is and not only that to
make sure that you don't break that that
confidentiality grant that means nothing
because you used it to hide crime ah
yeah oh great argument great argument
Joe good luck with it against the
Manhattan D.A and the testimony of of
not only not only Michael Cohen but
several Trump allies like Kelly and
Conway and hope Hicks okay yeah so you
could have said no comment or he could
have said I don't know anything about it
which is what he did but that's the
right I would advise my client to do the
same thing he's speaking to some whether
it's a journalist or some young lady on
December 2016 is the exact date but but
whether he's speaking to a a journalist
or some young lady on the street just
shouted out a question that is not the
form for him to go into detailed
questions about a confidential
settlement agreement oh Joe you just you
just said that's the advice that I would
give that's the advice that I would give
my my client oh man how long do you
think it takes for this guy not to have
a law license what do you think
what do you think you think by the end
of the year this guy doesn't have a long
license what do you think do you think
do you think um this guy's gonna be
ramped up in a criminal investigation
um based on him trying to hide more
Donald Trump's crime somewhere else
there seems to be plenty of them there
seems to be [__] plenty of them to
try to cover up and hide
whether it's attorney-client privilege
with John Eastman or a confidentiality
agreement
or or or oh uh the presidential records
act those are my documents and I
Declassified them
this seems to be a pattern
there just seems to be a criminal
pattern here with the Cheeto dusk you
and honor Jill you're not that
impressive
you really aren't I I think there's one
more clip out there that I want to show
Ari
let's see if I can look it up here there
it is oh let's see if I can find this
there's one more clip out there I'm
gonna show you because I have a few
minutes left why not why not again he
goes he grabs he tries to uh grab uh Ari
by the by the receipts
[Music]
oh here he goes this is the clip uh
Sarah Reese Jones has this clip
um this is on the same interview and
asking about the Jan six trial listen
your case would you defend him on
January 6th I listen what I'm not going
to do is go into I don't know about all
these other cases
you don't even know about the Stormy
Daniels case [__] we have
already established this in the last
commentary that I just gave on the two
minute clip where you claim Donald Trump
didn't lie when he lied and then you
claimed that he's just trying not to
break the CR the confidentiality
agreement that he used to cover up the
[__] the [__] crime of the bribe
and the fine campaign Finance violation
the [__] out of here you don't even know
about the case you're defending him he
had to ask Ari about the dates of the
videos where Donald Trump spoke on the
case yeah [__] break I hope he
defends him in all these cases but let's
listen if I Believe In the case I would
certainly think that's why do you
believe in the case I don't know enough
about it I believe in him I will tell
you that I believe
a joke
oh my God he's not going to go into
hypotheticals he can't even go into
non-hypotheticals like um hearing that
Donald Trump lied and then knowing that
he [__] lied he just didn't tell the
truth that's not a lie Ari he just
didn't tell the truth okay that's not a
lie well what's a [__] lie then if it
ain't telling something that ain't the
truth the [__] out of here
I know what happened January 6th so
would you represented Kimberly Guilfoyle
in that would you take Donald Trump's
January 6th defense Donald Trump yeah I
don't what did he do wrong I mean if you
take the case
I'm interviewing you
this guy doesn't even know it's an
interview all right remember it's like
what the [__] are you talking about
listen
just answer the question I'm asking you
a question you answer it and and if
you've noticed there he did disclose
because he realized that he needs to
disclose that he did defend Kimberly
Guilfoyle when they were doing the
deposition for the January 6 select
committee but but was it the select
committee or is it the grand jury
because he said he defended Kimberly
Guilfoyle if you caught that but let's
listen would you take the case what's
what she said for a minute someday we
will would you take that case if they
asked me to take it and there were a
case depending on what the alligators
were of course it's also a matter of
depending all right yeah depending I
can't just say I'll take any case I
don't do that
[Laughter]
by a system and it makes me sick to my
stomach
I give this guy I don't know I give him
[__] what nine months [__]
doesn't have a law license
I mean that'd take long for these Trump
attorneys to lose their law license
someone someone asked here let me see if
I can find it uh back here someone asked
does he think he'll he'll ever get paid
[__] no I mean unless this guy is
demanding money up front and he's gotten
paid some money he'll keep that money uh
I I want to find the comment here but
let's see where the hell is it they have
so many comments there's a lot of
comments today there's a lot of comments
oh man this guy whoosh whoosh let's see
if there's another clip there's a couple
others this this interview was quite
quite some time
uh here we go here's here's another clip
uh asking if um it'll catapult him to
the White House listen to this because
this will show how they are weaponizing
the justice system they're taking the
vote out of the voters Hey Joe that's
not really relevant is it oh it's
certainly relevant what's not with
relevant to what relevant to watch his
innocence either he's innocent or not
like who gives a [__] who gives a [__]
if this guy's running for president or
they're or they're trying to do this to
stop him from running for president he's
either guilty or innocent of these
charges
he's either guilty or innocent what the
[__] what the [__] does him running for
president have to do with these charges
that he tried to Bri other than he
shouldn't be running for president
because he's he's [__] using bribes
and campaign he's breaking campaign
Finance laws to get elected
what what the [__] are you talking about
aerobics was innocence he's innocent and
if they bring this case because he's
innocent this will catapult him to the
White House yeah they don't catapult him
to the White House now that's a bunch of
[__] but I'm telling you I'm telling
you this is gonna catapult him to the
Republican nomination just [__] you
you sit back and you doubt me on this
I do it do it I dare you I dare you to
do it as if I'm not right all the
[__] time
ah you're the best audience in the world
I love having you here yeah we're
running out of time it happens that way
it happens that way and I'm gonna do
some Shameless promotion here at the end
because you guys you guys have been
supporting me
um so so much in the last few weeks
um it it actually it is very comforting
to know that there are people not only
people out there that want to listen to
the show that that know exactly what I'm
talking about that know why it's so
important to get our narrative and our
messaging straight to get it on the
right path to make sure that we pound
the drum from now until 2024 and even
after because these Nazis are at our
front door they're here they're here and
if you don't believe me I'll show you
the video again in Ohio
um what they're trying to do by by
demonizing groups of people in this
country and what they're trying to do to
gain power whether it's Ron DeSantis
Donald Trump or anyone any other of
these Nazis
so
let's let's let's
um stick together in this and let's grow
this audience I believe I believe the
audience
um loves this show and I think this show
is going to be one of the hottest
political shows out there and the reason
why is because I am not scared to say
the truth I'm not scared to tell you
exactly how it is I'm not gonna butter
it up I'm not gonna I'm not gonna set
for anybody
I'm just going to tell you exactly how I
feel in the commentary and I'm going to
go after these son of a [__] that are
trying to destroy our democracy
and I'm going to give you the the
ammunition that you need to go out and
engage in your democracy and to make
sure that our microphones are louder
than theirs
and I appreciate all your support rather
you like this share it you subscribe to
the YouTube channel whatever it is just
go to thetonymichaels.com that's the
Tony michaels.com you will find all the
links there now you can follow the
YouTube channel that was on suspension
for seven days you can follow us on
Twitter at Tony Michaels pod you can
download every single episode all the
links are there you can follow us on
Facebook
at the Tony Michaels go follow the up
wires Channel theupwired.com and follow
us on Twitch and make sure if you have
an Amazon Prime account to link your
Amazon Prime account to Twitch it's a
free way for you to give us monetary
support if you have a Prime account you
get one free subscription on Twitch and
you can give us that one free
subscription when you link
when you link your Amazon Prime account
to our Twitch account
and give us that free subscription
and it gives us money that's right or
you can go over to patreon patreon's
another way to give to give money and
you get extras we get you get early
access to Clips you get the Sunday rants
it's another way to support the show
another way to support the show is go to
the merch store
it's all there at the tonymichaels.com
but this week is hat week that's right
it's [__] em hat week
so if you go to
hats.tonymichaels.com that's
hats.tonymichaels.com or you just go to
the Tony michaels.com scroll down and
hit the hat store use the promo code
hats10 that's
h-e-t-s-10 hats 10. you can use that
promo code and get 10 off your entire
[__] em hats order so go get your [__]
em hats now at
hats.detonymichaels.com or go to the
Tony michaels.com scroll down hit the
hat store and use the promo code hats10
I appreciate you guys being here every
single day
it's a line it's two hours a day and we
want to get the three hours we're gonna
get there quick I have a feeling we're
gonna grow this audience and we're going
to get there fast quick and in a hurry
to make sure to save our democracy like
we did in 2022 we're gonna do it again
in 2024.
and it's because of you the greatest
audience in the world give our mods a
lot of love they had some trouble in the
chat today YouTube's acting up it's a
thing [__] them you know [__] them and
until tomorrow Surf's Up [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon